our hometown NFL football team the New
England Patriots have been pulled into
the Donald Trump vortexes I like to
refer to it this is from Donald Trump's
a final appeal to new hampshire voters
last night let's take a look talking
about New England Patriots quarterback
Tom Brady Oh a couple of things to
people i have a lot of respect for
really like as people credible people
and because they're so important to the
area i thought i would give you this
information they've told me i can do it
yeah so i will do it tom brady great guy
great minutes
great guy great friend of my great great
champion unbelievable winner he called
today yeah and he said Donald I support
you you're my friend and I voted for you
and I want to tell you this guy is a
champ and he is a winner and he is a
great person yeah so there was a lot of
confusion about this because yesterday
morning Tom Brady was asked on Boston
morning radio have you taken advantage
of early voting and he said no I haven't
voted yet and then we saw a few tweets
including one from yahoo news is Hunter
Walker saying that up records show Tom
Brady's voter registration is currently
inactive and he's not enrolled in a
party but then we found out as reported
by Comcast SportsNet New England that
Donald Trump sorry that Tom Brady did
show up and vote by turning in an
absentee ballot according to the
Brookline Massachusetts town clerk's
office but then there's more confusion
because uh there was a an Instagram post
to Tom Brady's wife gisele bundchen
saying hey Giselle I heard you and Tom
were backing Trump is that true and she
responded with no so this is all very
very odd and to be honest I wish nobody
would be dumb enough to be influenced in
their vote by who Tom Brady voted for
but sadly I think there probably are
people that low information would they
would say Oh Tom Brady voted for X or Y
well then count me in well it's
interesting that Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick would be so public about this
too because they're looked at as
champions and heroes in this area it's
very blue area of New England so this
would be contradictory to what the
opinions of most of the people here I
agree with you and it also got weird
when Donald Trump then read a letter he
claimed to be from NFL patriots NFL new
england patriots team coach bill
belichick which sounds totally fake but
apparently has since been confirmed by
Bill Belichick listen to this he's a
champ so he sent me the new letter and
it was much better it was stronger
see most people don't do that most
people of the opposite oh gee I don't
want to get involved this guy is a true
champ so he writes coach Belichick
congratulations on a tremendous campaign
you have dealt with an unbelievable
slanted and negative media and have come
out beautifully beautiful you've proved
to be the ultimate competitor and
fighter your leadership is amazing oh I
have always had tremendous respect for
you but the toughness and perseverance
you have displayed over the past year is
remarkable hopefully tomorrow's election
results will give the opportunity to
make America great again
best wishes for great results tomorrow
bill belichick so I just yeah let's put
the letter up real quick I mean did this
is one of the stupidest letters a pair I
thought this was definitely fake because
it mentions tremendous twice and talks
about you know make America great again
it looks like the letter Trump would
write and say that Bill Belichick wrote
uh but I guess Bill Belichick really
wrote this um it's so bizarre and my
impression of Bill Belichick is
drastically destroyed by this because
it's such a stupid letter and he says
that Trump made it out beautifully after
all the critiques from the media which I
would have to disagree with it you
you're right that anything could have
triggered this guy to all of a sudden
write a letter to Donald Trump but it's
all very very stupid in a few tweets to
show you about this one is from again
yahoo uses Hunter Walker who said he
tried calling balichek to ask about this
in the bell check hung up on him and
then Charlie Pierce from Esquire
magazine tweeted Belichick is known for
being quite supporter of democratic
politicians of liberal causes I smell an
orange mange rat behind that letter also
the owner of the New England Patriots
Bob Kraft a a known Democrat and liberal
uh it's all very very disturbing because
I really thought that Bill Belichick in
all aspects of his life was just a
bright and informed guy and if he did
write a letter to trump using the word
tremendous twice my my opinion of Bill
Belichick has absolutely changed and it
stinks because i love the Patriots you
know I do Pat but this is pretty
horrifying yeah i mean my opinion
towards athletes having opinions and
sharing them on politics is pretty low
yeah I don't really care one way or
another but it's really taking charge
over the past few years we now see Colin
Kaepernick protesting the national
anthem yeah and the story just keeps
coming back in different ways Curt
Schilling former red sox who now saying
all sorts of crazy right-wing stuff i
mean it's just all it's all a disaster
but i guess you know they believe will
win again if Trump is president it's sad
I'll tell you that gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as
many games as you want for one monthly
fee and if you find some games you want
to keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s